Leyna starts off this hour in Illinois
hi Linna how are you hi Dave I'm well
how are you better than I deserve what's
up so I have a house in this area and
it's sitting empty and I'm in the
process of finding penance and I'm going
to be profiting about a hundred and
fifty dollars a month from my expenses
for that property once I get a tenant in
there so I'm wondering if I throw all of
that at the principle of the mortgage do
I still owe on it
because I actually want to sell this
house in a couple years I don't want to
keep it I don't want to be a landlord
right and that's it I want to keep it
until I get married and then once we're
like married and everything's legal then
I will sell it but I want to keep it you
know stuff can go bad you never know
what's going to happen
my boyfriend could die you never know
what could happen so I want to keep it
in case I need it until I'm legally
married when are you getting married
when he asks that's pretty good not
engage my boyfriend well we're not
engaged she's my boyfriend we don't know
there's no room there's no proposal so
yeah live together I mean he's debt-free
so I moved into his house rented mine I
still own it but I want to keep it in
case I ever need to go back there for
whatever for if anything happens to him
so that's what I'm trying to figure out
now so five years from now you're still
sitting here no I don't think so I wanna
know we will be getting we we will be
getting married it's just a matter of
when he asks it's the conversations been
had so I know it's coming I don't know
when but it's going to happen so and
I've been married before and actually
divorced so we've talked about this so
once the question comes it will there
will be no engagement that will be
immediately so that's were up so I just
don't know what to do at this house
until that happens well I mean the thing
is if you're married in 90 days and you
have a sick
monthly sure sitting on a year landlord
I'm okay with being a landlord for short
term a couple years I don't want to be a
landlord for more than two years I just
want you to be a landlord
I don't want well I uh my boyfriend's
gonna take care of a lot of it I have a
really really great well you know what
you know what I would do I would move
back into the house okay that's what I
would do I'd move back into it and stay
there until you're getting married and
when you get married sell the house okay
I definitely want it sold like once I
marry they don't want to be there plenty
though yeah I just I I wouldn't keep it
as well as a rental property for one day
yeah I I don't you need a back if you
need a back stop and you're worried
about a place to go you need to be over
there living okay well it's easy enough
for me to get back there yeah that's
what I would do I would live there until
you're married and then when you're
married you sell your house and move in
with your husband of course that would
be normal that's what I would do okay